saluant ce magnifique lundi avec ce
magnifique temps à l'extérieur on est
revenu en hiver je vous présente le blog
de la semaine ya quelques jours j'ai été
invité au théâtre trévise pour la
première des coups de blues de l'humour
là bas et je vous ai emmené avec moi et
petite annonce le blog de la semaine
prochaine sera sur la dernière de mon
plateau hallucination collective et
autres illusions fantastique qui a lieu
ce soir à 21h30 si vous êtes sur paris
ce soir 21h30 on fait la dernière y aura
kamel le magicien il y aura zapata y
aura philippe ross djamel kaibou
également artus et puis bien sûr moi
sinon ça n'a pas trop de sens et si vous
venez faites le moi savoir à la fin
j'aimerais bien faire de trois images
avec vous pour le vlog mais pour le
moment je vous emmène dans les loges tu
vlog gvt l'oeil allume ta caméra et tu
dis voilà comment les deux prochaines
heures c'est moi qui vais vous parler
c'est toi qui parle du corps bon ben je
blogue
et après après je fais une marne une
routine battue m'a perdu et je couds
jamais mis une baffe déjà dit mais je
sais exactement cheveux verts allaient
vers la stabilité a fait ça c'est alex l
est qui on a fait la vidéo
merci alex maintenant c'est vraiment
parfait la vidéo ballon tu me réponds
pas mes messages facebook mais arrête
tes conneries tout le monde devant
caméras et préfère voir mais merci à
plus et du coup mon dernier message
elles n'ont non désolé j'étais pas dispo
taille demain on essaye de se recaler ça
vite et je mets ça marque dix mois de
dispo mais ça donne je filme que tu me
files mme filippetti jean match ça va
trouver un outil est ce que quelqu'un
veut réellement voir le trou noir de
jean phi oui on va beaucoup c'est un
reich gros buzz de mettre un sondage en
fin de vidéo pour bien enfoncer à jouer
mon jeu sans consentement ou sont dits
oui c'est vrai si jamais cette image là
durant quelques secondes
il y aura 50 commentaires de ati voit
les tout petits à cause des mecs comme
toi que je souffre tous les abonnés
peuvent réagir maintenant il faut dire
les choses à ses ingénieurs et les coups
de blues de bursa se passe au théâtre du
trévise le magnificat du trévise
je monte sur scène pour vous faire voir
là évidemment le public n'est pas encore
rentrée
sinon on pourrait dire qu on allait
passer une bonne soirée sans vouloir
tout commander c'est quand même ce que
tu fais on n'a pas bien entendu voir
qu'on me filme en plus on m'a même pas
demandé mon avis vous rendez compte pour
une meuf qui aiment pas qu'on la filme
elle se colle bien près de la caméra
quand même
qu'est ce que j'ai à dire là on est à
dix minutes du spectacle et en loge je
trouvais pas l'équipe d'organisation ou
est ce qu'ils peuvent être juste avant
le spectacle
un soir après soir électrique vidéo dans
une photo avec keiko mathis soulevé que
je préfère mourir libres une vidéo avec
enfin une photo avec gaëtan on va se
mettre dans l'avion
les gens regardent ils arrêtent pas
jésus rejet ces cinq ans c'est comme ça
je suis parfois je distribue des trucs à
la fin jean louis j'accepte moi je dis
aux idéaux défendus en vie car je te
mets le bon ici te mets ton bon de droit
à l'image était donc fabien olicard film
avec canal ascendant du transfert de
super matos cannon et d'ailleurs s'il
écoute je veux bien échantillons jeu
j'aime beaucoup je viens échantillons
sets 5-7 des envies du monde s'est bien
gardée comme quand tu vois un mec faire
ça avec une chaise tu t'es dit forcément
il entend qu'il va pas personne ne
comprend que tu peux t'asseoir la digue
la loge du trévise qui on retrouve quand
même des vieilles affiches à noter que
découlent
celle de paul terral et celle de
caussens au mont pestacles alaba rose or
no pas majeur gidoin non à attendre non
plus nos abonnés
je crois que les gens commencent à
rentrer allons vos nerfs
vous voulez savoir un truc drôle je sais
pas encore ce que je vais faire sur
scène puisque encore décidé
faut pas le dire à didier à edouard leur
programme on passe et on met dans le
cadre des choses bas à la réalisation
didier fauré s'est pas laissé
impressionner alex et sa guitare on
regarde on peut faire couliou il a mal
rangée qu'on n'a jamais appelé monsieur
fabien au but pour voir des consciences
est bon en huit embryons et a88 les
coups de 16 heures
allez-vous le connaître le secret de
poster 10 contre le trac quatrième usa
comme annoncé sur quatre c'était un
petit peu tout à fait normal
deuxième à rien
réduits on se connait grand timide et je
sais mais bon je crois encore
franchement si c'est encore pour se
moquer de vignes et forêts j'ai le train
de finaliser le pas du tout plus avant
se moquer de billets indifférent
déconner je sais pas je ne sais plus qui
est notre directeur artistique de son
choix
du talent ça serait un peu chiche c'est
parti
quelque chose me dit que c'est parti
m
alors
oui les amis bienvenue à tous il faut
savoir que cette soirée a débuté pour la
première fois ce festival d'avignon il
ya des gens qui sont super la dgt points
communs
un camion énorme pression mais moi je
peux faire le premier plan et toi tu
donnes la richesse du coup je me parle
de la situation je la joue je te fais
une bague ouverte et je souris mais ça
dépend tu veux le côté cinématographique
tuer ou théâtrales cendrillon sur
recettes de ta billetterie non ça c'est
le dégoût la déception l'humiliation non
mais vous voyez c'est vraiment là les
commerçants dépression
c'est que là je me suis dit il faut que
je me méfie de ce mec assis s'achève les
coups de blues et l'humour merci didier
merci fabien tu étais contente parfois
real grave grave public hyper réactif et
tous étaient à quai et puis je suis
surtout content de vos passages à tous
respectivement qu'ils ont fait vraiment
et le 15 mai on dira pas qui parce qu'on
veut peuvent faire mal aux carabins non
on dira pas j'en fis va peut être
falloir dire à jean philippe que c'est
bien ce tous les temps qui viennent de
voir soyez riche sur l'îlot me voilà une
chaîne de personnes qui sont sans qu'il
y ait fêté deux passages de gués tomatis
je sais pas sur quelle jambe
je trouve que ça c'est un meilleur
chrono en fait moi de dire venez me voir
c'est par exemple ce soir il ya des
partis religieux plus jubilatoire que
faire rire les gens que de faire hurler
les cons elle est sage que c'est un vrai
plaisir de base se sent ça marche et ça
a été la plaque de rue porret la mairie
leur manteau elles sont parties au matin
non mon dieu mais c'est trop celui de
plusieurs de ses surfaces atteindront
pas aimé le port n'avait compagnie tu as
demandé à mike brant sur quoi toi l
affaire non non mais le vrai souci c'est
qu'on précise pas c'est que c'est un
spectacle pour enfants est mis dans
cette portion congrue
miss bala d'aller vers les joueurs et
sur youtube tin tin tin tin tin nouveau
trentenaire sur youtube tu glyphes tape
un tube if they live merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo si ça vous a plu de
nous voir dans notre environnement
naturel évolué tel un petit reportage
animalier
vous pouvez me le faire savoir laisser
un pouce en l'air n'oubliez pas
également de vous abonner à la chaîne
avant de partir parce que le mental blog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez vous de demain à 17h ciao
je